hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for Game of Thrones vol 3
this is the show where we talk about
that other show on this channel we used
to be on the other channel shut up
you'll get it if you don't know already
lon
Danielle Joe Dan this is everybody
responsible for honest trailers except
for the people who matter our editor
blends in and are the voice of course
john bailey and our graphics guy robert
Holtby who I believe it's his in if you
look at the old ones used to be just
like some big block arial sans-serif
thing I made those no they were terrible
cuz I would do them at 11 o'clock
tonight before the trailer and I was
really tired and so Robert was a godsend
you guys who's that hack that used to
make us I'm going to be talking about
Game of Thrones our behind-the-scenes
discussions that went into writing this
trailer we're gonna watch the trailer
yell pause people get mad when that
doesn't happen immediately talk about
what's happening if you stick around to
the end you'd say all the deleted scenes
that we didn't make it into and finally
the questions that you fans have that
we'll be responding to so put your
questions in the comments of the honest
trailer and you can see us make fun of
you here next week this is known as glad
we get to actually reply it's a life you
screw something up like forget that
Michael Myers as I might be messed up
because Jamie Lee Curtis stabbed him
with a hanger that was just living with
it in the comments forever we could
actually say like you are bad sorry or
no your bed so it's interesting that
we're starting with this one Game of
Thrones vol 3 is like what watching
Thrones or a million other Internet
videos but just take a quick temperature
season 6 through 8 Game of Thrones
starting you it's fine it's fine
it was fine Lana I know you're fairly
positive yeah I was not as I mean
it has his problems but I was not as
down on it as everyone else it ruined it
for me Joe I really need the Wheel of
Time series to come out sooner than
later now Oh was that just bad need
better fantasy thing too I liked the
last particularly the last season more
than this trailer does but I acknowledge
that it has several errors most of them
unforced so yeah yeah what's wrong with
you people
sighs with me and I'm the angriest one
this they blew it they they completely
blew it and I say that is I think they
blew it in for a tribute to how much you
loved the show testify if you were
paying attention take me to church the
more you pay attention the more they got
wrong escort chapel because the more you
were tracking these characters I know
one you're gonna disagree with me
because you were also paying attention
cuz it's also your job but the more
invested you were and the more you
thought about it it was almost insulting
how little they seemed to think about it
or how how little they gave you in terms
of sophistication and depth in those
finals yeah I don't know if I agree in
terms of sophistication
it's just rushed I think everybody
agrees or at least everybody this table
agrees that they didn't give themselves
enough time to do all the things that
they clearly wanted to do and needed to
do to resolve all of these storylines I
think that goes across the board I think
we'd all agree with that necessarily
means that the storytelling lacks
sophistication I think they did a pretty
good job considering the limitations
they put on themselves self-imposed
lactation I agree yeah don't disagree
with that I just think that that's
different than saying this storytelling
lacks sophistication that's they were
just they were rushing headlong into it
I think a lot of the things they did
still worked really well it's just that
they had to sacrifice a lot as they were
rushing so much yeah I feel like it was
like a trip to like the Caribbean I was
on a cruise to the Caribbean and then
like 3/4 of the way through like
somebody came into my room would beat me
up and threw me like in the Brig
the end like we got to the Caribbean
Alice just like I it's not I don't I
don't mind where we are I just did you
have to beat me up on the way here and
like lock me up in the Brig it's like
getting your ass kicked in Sydney I mean
I know the internet said that a million
times
yeah I'm at the Caribbean but I'm
questioning how I got there there's so
many things now that I'm glad didn't end
up making it or this show Lady
Stoneheart you know more of the Lord of
Light stuff because none of it none of
it mattered they dumped so much lore
into the show and then like like David
Brent said it like they won't remember
and I did remember because I liked those
things I don't know if part of it is
like the show started off as like the
anti Dungeons & Dragons and then jumped
headlong into Keebler elves and John
coming back to life and stuff and then
took a hard right back into the anti
Dungeons & Dragons and it's too much
whiplash for tone but yeah yeah the
appeal was so much the shades of grey
over the first five seasons or six
seasons really where it's like you know
there's pitfalls of seeking power
whether you're doing it for good reasons
or bad reasons it can corrupt you and
you can be a good person in some
respects and not others and it just kind
of turned into the forces of good versus
the forces of evil
charging at each other really truly I
think a lot of the things that bugged
people about the last season is they
wanted it to end definitively with like
Jaime Lannister's redeemed he's good now
and like the show didn't do that and
that's what bugged people it's like it
leveled it on this and
did say Jaime Lannister's redeemed he's
good now it we went through that whole
jury and thrown in the brig of the
cruise ship that's exactly what you're
saying was lacking that's like he's okay
that's like a grayscale like a nice
color shift from from you know dark to
light and then that's life people get
clean and then they realize it's it's
not the result it's the method I think
is and I agree it's like it's not so
much where things ended up it's in fact
that it's how we got there where we
spend the time where the show spent its
time the way that it told the story I I
the one thing that I'm in favor of on a
character level is what happened with
Daenerys I think that her going mad
makes total sense given what the show
set up but I will agree that the method
in which they set that Ark and that turn
up in the final season was rushed and
was not they could if it handles more
care I think it would have had a much
bigger impact it's a like I like where
they ended up I just think getting there
to really tie themselves in knots to get
hurt and kill innocent poor people yeah
well they support Cersei and she they do
this by choices like no you're smarter
than that you know it's not their choice
but if they'd taken five episodes to set
that up I think they could have done it
in of myself yeah the whole thing works
if you buy that Jon and Daenerys love
each other like to me that's the
downfall of that whole plotline is that
it doesn't emotionally pay off at the
end like you wanted to because you just
don't care about them as a couple like
you did Johnny oh they're for three
months we just never it was too rushed I
think we never really felt that
connection between the two of them so
the way that it ends up you're like okay
well I figured that might happen it is
emotional yes the show's gonna be four
hours long I started
as it goes trailer starts at whatever
the sides of my favorite dude game would
throw you cowards I mean we are we were
afraid a standard internet comment
it was the highest-rated show of its era
the most talked about pop culture event
object decade and by the 10 no it's fine
a season's wanna watch it against
letdowns and TV media streamer think o
have grabbed the broken protector of the
realm
[Music]
there is no situation in which the price
is right you fail for this is in the
deleted scenes but we had John try to
sing the Curb Your Enthusiasm theme song
The Price is Right horn funny silly
funny yeah I think that if that actually
played in your life after something you
did like that would scar you for life if
you like messed something up and
somebody played that in real time doing
well I have to go die
only offset that by having that carry a
defensive dance hall here fair enough I
got a skip come don't George RR Martin's
doorstop novels returns but since they
already burned through those they're
going off an outline and boy does it
feel that my paws were after one so as
far as the show we all agreed that it's
rushed now the theories for why it's
rushed include they were working on Star
Wars instead it's Kathleen Kennedy spoke
[Laughter]
reddit right because they made the
decision with HBO on how to finish up
the show before the Lucasfilm deal was
done - yet I don't think the timeline on
that actually works but do you think
that the reason they hurried it up is
because they ran out of books and they
only had bullet points I maintain that
there should be some mention in the
historical record of the fact that they
did not sign up to finish
I guess Song of Ice and Fire and I'm
like I even went back and was looking at
articles when they announced the show
like all of the news and the comments
were like back from 2010 we're just like
you know the series is expected to come
to an end within you know 10 years which
will give george RR martin plenty of
time to finish his on like they did not
sign on to this thing with the fate with
the knowledge of like oh and by the way
you're gonna get the first crack at the
ending i think that that is part of the
equation i think that's part of the
equation that's a good point
they probably not saying it have you
more bucks to drugs oh yes fault but i
think it played a part and the other
thing is i mean Star Wars specifically
aside when you make a show like this
that becomes the hottest show in the
world you are constantly getting offers
from to do other amazing things and I
think that after a while anybody would
be like I think George RR Martin's now
instead of finishing his books will go
to any kind of con
any compilations you a nice device
probably most likely everyone involved
was having some sort of a member of
their families like you care more about
Game of Thrones
yeah of your family yeah more expensive
right it's harder to shoot the show it's
more expensive to shoot the show the
logistics of ten times more difficult
these aren't excuses I think they're
contributing factors that doesn't change
how the show was written but I think it
contributes to why it was the way those
yeah I don't think it's a massive
conspiracy or like they just really I
think it was like a canoe a bunch of
different things like it's hard to do
something like this for like a decade
that's why there's so few big shows they
keep going that that had probably sucked
Danny bad the original alan has john
bangin arya so this whole thing about
pie we're after one mixed season that
still full of some major high I like
saying yes yeah I definitely agree in it
safe Oh Doris is amazing disagree this
may be because the show runners either
got bored burnt out or bitter that no
one like their slavery r.i.p we can't
talk in there cuz then there's all
people sit like pause much right wanna
see those trailer click one video and
watch it then come back and then times
right the balance
just the wrong idea and the wrong time
oh it was the wrong place at the
extremely wrong time I think that just
means it's wrong yeah just just wrong
but good for that nothing nothing about
that is good there's not even the Nugget
of the seed of life you think you'd see
that do you think after all that went
down they were so pissed that Joss
Whedon's snuck it in through the sci-fi
Avenue with Firefly totally the
Confederates lost the war with
spaceships yeah I think there's just
like suck it well it's kind of like the
man in the high castle - it's just like
different right a different war yeah no
but it was a different everything it was
like modern wasn't the pitch like modern
games like wouldn't life be a lot easier
[Laughter]
you just keep talking and I start fading
away like that
featuring
huge revelations that never really pay
off you know the true king humor has
chosen to say no it's just it's bench
relations that human danger though
turning on a dime stay with me and
characters who straight up for consent
that best friend ejecting powers or for
God who they're at war with Danny kind
of forgot about the iron fleet she
forgot her god the biggest Navy in
Westeros existed admitted this o show
was an elaborate plot for you to meet ed
Sheeran yeah yeah I'm not one I'm not
one to I don't want to pile on I what
they often why I said to do with the
shows impossible but you don't do
yourself but many favors when you know
that you're gonna be explaining an
episode and you know it's gonna air
directly after the episode and the thing
about why you're flying character with a
huge sight line of sight I didn't see a
bunch of ships that
I mean the tactical enemy with since you
forgot about them just like know
yourself like there are things in the
show only that rock hadn't been there I
think the answers like just own it you
know like you never yeah never win by
explaining something like that it's
always better to just be nice choose him
dramatic license yeah even the show has
established many times over that anytime
a large party is moving that they always
send scouting think mmm characters
making mistakes I think we say on the
trailer characters making mistakes
aren't plot holes but that was just so
egregious that's like an entire army
sessions that would be like if the night
king walked up behind Jon Snow with his
army and tapped him on the shoulder and
you're like how the hell did they get
there they're like Jon kind of forgotten
excuse for anybody but I do think this
is like they're getting all the blame
but the blame goes around for something
like that because also you could shoot
that sequence in a way that doesn't make
it feel so egregious but they don't they
shoot it in a way that makes it feel
extra egregious where you can visibly
see that she has the ability to see this
army and then she doesn't like votes yet
from certain angles they're behind a
rock German tourists in Miami ways to
suggest like the confusion of the scene
or her lack of visibility on the dress
there's a million things you can either
just like this man yeah yaagh
I usually yeah they have like they have
this alchemist that helped her build a
giant green napalm bomb yeah and a
crossbow bigger yeah they called us
quarry figure out some fog it's like
it's a bonus
here's the thing at least uh here's the
thing if it would have been fog which
would have solved one plot hole then the
next one would have been like so you
were telling me that your are gradually
in the fog there was no motive had to
get close I think miss Dix our plot
holes would have worked if she was just
cocky because she's like I'm on a dragon
and then paid the price for she got a
two-column yeah yeah yeah or she does
what she did later in the show which is
that she has a lot of hubris that
dive-bombs the iron fleet sure I could
do it that way but whatever she forgot
we won't harp on this moment the
Internet has done plenty that's our
dialogue that's creative areas
especially the entire city to the desert
their players will finally collide to
see who will sit on the Iron Throne will
the reign of Queen Cersei continue or
will she just stare out the window I
mean you know it's like a house of cards
like once he's president there's nothing
for different eras continue our surgical
attacks against the ruling class or will
she 420blaze the world when her nephew
will give her the D no I think I didn't
understand any of that so okay so I do
I do but it's very spotter I get that's
a bit of hyperbole but it was very
modern since provide this is like the
one line in the script that we as a room
came together to perfect little
contribution it lays everyone will see
420 blaze is the D no more the nephew D
yeah this is why it's so valuable to
work with the writers room get your
squad yeah that's that line got filtered
through all five I guess all four sorry
yeah what happened was vacation oh it's
gone yeah I'm okay yeah all right
charlie yeah anyways let's keep going
yes or will she 420 blaze the world and
her nephew gave her the Dean Award if
she had just burned down the red key
like you
no we're gonna we're gonna talk about
this because Danny people like one of
the defenses of this is like you know
that is what happens in Medan medieval
times I know this isn't a real show like
sieges of cities and you would burn down
you know an entire garrison worth of
troops or an entire civilian population
to conquer a land it's just that's not
what she's had so many chances to do
that and has never done that she's
always put the people first always I
would argue that there's been times like
with the masters and stuff once you
crucified our masters which is like the
2% that's putting a stranglehold on
everybody else that is who took out the
deep stage it's always been there were
many times her first instinct was
unparalleled cruelty and she said I'm
gonna do this horrible thing to send a
message and she had advisors like like
Sir Jorah and Tyrion and that we're
saying like don't do that because that's
that is not you don't want if you don't
want to rule by fear and this was the
ultimate chance of like all of that
whole support system been stripped away
and she could only see things and
failures of my enemies is not my way her
enemies were always the upper class
there was always directed at the lords
and ladies are the masters the last time
she liberated a city everyone came
running out of the gate saying Mesa Mesa
and was like carrying her and then she
shows up she's liberating and all of the
people are running away from her saying
like help me my queen helping likely she
got pissed off she's like no you know
what I'm liberating you screw you you're
my enemy
they really went but they vacillated
with how much she knows or doesn't know
about Westeros because like in the early
seasons like her brother had told her
everything and she knows about the
Lannisters and she would she would know
that these people are innocent I mean I
think the one thing I would take issue
with what you're saying is I think
you're you're assuming that it's
class-based which is very modern
like the Daenerys I know no if this
really was up in medieval times she
would give a [ __ ] she loves the porridge
it's never been it's never been done
class she's very aristocratic capitalist
and that's how she sees the world she
doesn't see herself as like a Marxist or
it's like we're gonna see the brick
breaking that's that's in clear the in
terms of like slavery like she eats it's
about personal freedom but it's not
about economic freedom it's gonna I mean
this usually a slave I don't know that
slaves have a lot of economic freedom
though right that's what I'm saying I'm
saying she's about
she's about ending the practice of
slavery but she's not about ending the
practice of like wage slavery no she's
keeping feudalism and he said standard
minimum wage economy a universal basic
income I think it's just the delivery
because I think the show did do a good
job setting this up her dream where she
runs into Aquaman in the kief and it's
snowing and that's obviously ash like
the show told us this was coming ages
ago but instead of doing like a really
solid arc they they started an arc and
then she just turned into remember when
Fred Flintstone like the bowling ball
would hit his head and he would turn
into an evil mobster she's tough on her
killed
another writers discussion based on
three-position credit anyways let's keep
watching anything I never wanted a crowd
don't want it I never want that I told
you again I don't want it I never have
know the winner at the end of it all he
is the character with the best story and
who has a better story and brand the
brick and so many people read its name
one branch the creepy ass kid no but
like literally anyone else I brain does
not have the best story about any of
these characters yeah I can kind of see
what Tyrion would things I think that
that makes more sense if you see through
Tyrians eyes then just a read is like
this year's the showrunners talking to
you sure but there's you know twelve
people voting on it speaking
anachronistic radical stuff yes and they
would all be like no what I really think
you miss in the in the rush to get to
that seemed it I would have really loved
to see his and this is not even just in
terms of brand story but like the whole
show was we never got a sense for the
news from the north making it to the
rest of Westeros the night King right
does anyone believe this [ __ ] exactly I
would've loved more of a sense of were
there witnesses who went back and we
told everybody what they saw or like
some sort of way of passing what
knowledge and whatever guess yes far as
you know the Prince of Dorne is like
what are you guys hot
zombie got showed to everybody but
there's no oh yeah it meant dragonpit
where are the Ravens we assume that
there's no mail in the like south of
like the neck everybody is like that
didn't really happen yeah I want the
scene where they're explaining what
happened to the peasant tribe as like
you'd see minstrels telling people's
stories or you hear like plays or yeah
like some sense of here's how people
really they're hearing inaccurate
information about it or something that
one likes out I know I like the minstrel
idea
I wouldn't see Westeros is night king
truth is they were just like Winterfell
would have you believe thank you
but his body conveniently turned to ice
turned into an untraceable elements
undead fire can't melt magic ice yeah
it's snowed in 911 and say hello to
their one-dimensional look-alikes like
Varys
but of the dick joke if I lost my
clarification I was not happy with it
consider yourself this character also
show it to my brother for helping us
compile all of these clips yes yeah did
a speed watching because we in
Winterfell so much lurking yeah keep it
you still have it you left me to die
first I robbed you while the show's with
fabulous backslide from the Joffrey ask
Ramsay Bolton to the mysterious night
king who after all your fan theories
really was just some dude the Keebler
Elf stabbed to a tree to this soggy
pickup artist
he stole the dragon spot armor for
himself how does it be honest he's
making me a heart what Tim Burton movie
is historic Rob I take a dozen high
Sparrow lectures evermore the emo pretty
enough we have anything we tad
I really didn't like Kim versus J like
that they hadn't established that at all
it felt totally out of nowhere we knew
he liked Suzy we didn't know he felt
particularly competitive with Jaimie or
that he like dreamed of being the man
who was one day gonna kill Jamie
Lannister and gradually and then Jon
being
lianna's the breaker R + L equals J to
me felt like the two things inherited
from the novel's into the show that they
felt obliged to include that they had no
real sense narrative Lee of how to
actually operate and things like he in
the books is more it's got a magic horn
yeah he is like an absolute chaotic evil
like yeah I think they have it in the
show he rips the tongues out of his his
ship crew yes he likes to silence but
later on mentions it to him but they
almost the way they play it is almost
like it's a rumor like I heard this
crazy story about you Oh like it's not
confirmed but he is one of like the more
distict torturing and people with like a
mystic bent to him on a on a show or
book series full of that and instead
they turned him into like the swaggering
stuff yeah yeah it's it just it never
really comes together but but even even
that even this like weird kind of
half-formed character if you've done a
better job right away of being like he
has heard of Jamie Lazar do you like he
dreams of be going down in history is
that a bit of legwork on it so then when
that moment arrives were like oh oh he's
gonna get his chance instead of like
well why would you just go even just the
idea of just like there's all of the
stuff is the babies are seeing the baby
like the even planted stuff there's you
thinks it's this kid okay then have them
discover that it's not big enough
somebody's it for happy angry at Jamie
no yeah no he's just kind of like
there's more going on behind me fight
yes instead of that whole fight Jamie
could have just gotten hit with the
flour
let's finish chance I give God a lot to
go we live like one Tamar never dies can
still deliver some amazing visual
spectacles as soon as you remember how
to crank the brightness on your TV there
we go
from the closet or family goes the
Battle of the bastards to the ground
level chaos of the final computer Nanami
guys waiting for help on a frozen pond
[Laughter]
this is the worst example of run from
beyond the wall to wall to the wall then
Raven compose a raven catches breath
yeah pant out his message to a Meister I
guess cuz I was if Gendry can even read
or write I'm like and then that gets
sent to Dragonstone as the raven flies
it gets to Danny or or Varys or somebody
who has to who's her mail room I need to
call a meeting find her in the boning
cave
okay I've got a message like they're
already dead at this point their way
because it was like it seemed like it
was about let's say a date yeah because
it was it was the the ice had to freeze
back over yeah about a day it's very
unlike very unlikely that that was again
we're tightening is just like you did
you did i I get that you you have to be
there's a certain amount of narrative
convenience that you have to have but
that was again where it feels like you
hit fast forward and didn't really think
through there's probably a way to do
that logically and they just kind of
like yeah Nance is not always great yeah
I I've always been very loud as one of
the people who was like do you really
want to watch four episodes of two
people walking to another town but that
was one yes I do
was it was like the moment I mean the
most it was like so many good good stuff
but that show was like on their way to
something else that what I get no I
think they roll for perception zone
crazy scale the story the way it sort of
wound up the way they'd done it in like
season one it would have been like a
thirty season show yes sir okay put it
in my veins rest assured that in the
later seasons every commercialism and no
one you really care about is gonna die
this was ridiculous
Sam this is the one I can't really not
done with this Sam was screaming
single-handedly they all Glenn's but the
show that managed to both limb and
sprint to the finish line at the door on
giving it crap for not ending the way
you thought they can't please everybody
we're gonna be mad no matter what but
maybe not this many words at some point
yeah or even all the huge strategic
blunders the stakes aren't the same as
potholes no be grateful for a show
that's given us the last communal
experience in our divided world
crapping on the final seasons of Game of
Thrones
what do you mean White Fang what does
that mean get out of here oh yes White
Fang correct that's just like I love you
so much that I'm going to make the other
yeah it also happens in Game of Thrones
in season 1 the direwolf coming true
yeah I think I first heard it his White
Fang heartbreaking events he and Harry
Henderson oh right to be that said if
we're gonna just showed up in the last
episode was like ok for this story
yeah I was like crazy
[Music]
Harry Strickland propane propane
accessories and pause this is this could
be our fan questions somebody asked us
who wrote the Stephen H who wrote that
says Joe wrote that Harry Strickland
joke didn't he I did not how was it
Spencer or along
the pain was already on the page when we
were when we were from from king of it I
don't know who father doing watching
Thrones I think we might have been
writing about it yeah we definitely made
fun of the name matter who wrote what I
said Harry Strickland runs Strickland
payment Isle that was high all right
yeah well they will do will do all the
questions after these messages bad panel
shows save save questions - laughing
Harry Strickland says propane and
propane accessories all right our next
comedian you might have seen a north of
the wall turned into complete now it's
common growth pellets they actually
tried to make them it was actually kind
of scary and yes yeah yeah yeah like
he's he's very scary in this that's our
lucky man Kramer they'll be rolling
Banas flat service oh you're just gonna
murder me murder show about the shocked
faces correct yeah I'm so surprised like
watch your step my mortal enemy shippers
oh this is one of those things I didn't
realize it so you don't put together
good god this was so much a lot of ships
ship reverse ship I think we even cut a
lot of ship stuff out of it yeah yeah we
had a but we had a lot more chip shots
listen we don't have the men thing I was
shocked by how many tales then repeated
badly yeah but still I mean we have to
at this point the game stare montage of
the game trailers we have to do a you
know there's boobs trying to impress dad
is just so hard on you trade my cream
I'm pushed a boy this is a joke and
season
this was I remember I came up with this
for that see when I was watching it was
Jenny confess I made a terrible mistake
I made a mistake a horrible maybe
interesting make a terrible miss I tried
to do one of the dummer plants and I can
say okay underestimated my enemy Isis
cause everybody's in the score managed
Freddie Mercury
let's roll ready the deleted scene so
you see what's even less funny than that
yeah for a reason
through eight the show sell the show but
you don't have to take my word for it
just listen to all these happy satisfied
fans you people are in for much longer
about the cast members who gave
interviews but there's a long trailer so
they cut it down but then we cut it down
were like well if you lose the context
is it really worth it we're gonna we
just cut it off
yeah that was all them being asked about
how they feel about the ending of Game
of Thrones again as you can see you know
in character but out of character they
can contain and disgust on their faces
anyways let's keep showing the deleted
scenes you're a killjoy yeah smartest
dummy or the dumbest smart guy hey wave
stick around
that's funny he doesn't look Doris
Perkin film is just people being like
I'll never hurt you little brother
I'm tired of watching you coward I know
beat dog everything you did brought you
where you are now
where you belong oh shut up the upright
wildling brigade hopes confessional
stupor made a big debate of all super
was slightly not enough yeah Riggs
inbred get ready of him but he had to
wait to kill off one last thing the show
Martin Indyk oh so that's what you
missed for good reason
shall we take some some fan questions
response some comments yeah guys why do
we blur out nudity and take a cart
that's a good question
two reasons initially number one we used
to believe curse words and blur out
nudity because we wanted our shows to be
accessible still to you know I didn't
wanted to make it just for adults or
tasteful and get educated now you say
the worst thing is you get educated
we're nobody on YouTube you can see your
show unless they signed in you know if
you go past so we want to make sure that
didn't happen but in more recent years
it's because we do like making money
revenue is kind of an important thing
and increasingly YouTube has started as
a matter of fact this very video this
very trailer which we believe to word is
has been deemed and unsuitable for most
advertisers so it's because my game in
Thrones
dude to make some money I had revenue so
we have to attempted to adhere to the
policies of the platform that we
participate on plus if you're looking
for your nudity on YouTube you don't
know how to use the Internet wrong place
wrong place any mother spice and I
assume much like HBO we would not want
someone under 18 to be watching honest
trailers right
[Laughter]
another question oh wow why are TV
trailers so much less often well I can
answer that because it's a lot of TV to
watch movies are short comparatively
they're about two to three hours long
depending on the film and TV shows are
so long which isn't as much an issue for
the writing as it is the editing yeah
really is a pain in the ass for our
editors to have to sift through hundreds
of episodes of television even mentioned
we brought in help on the writing side
just to go through all the episodes to
find the time codes everything like
stuff like the runs with you know Jon
Snow saying he doesn't want to do things
right that's somebody going through the
entire show and like looking for all of
those moments and honestly we also
challenge ourselves like we could have
actually done a five-minute honest
trailer for these three seasons and just
adhere to the Internet talking points
you know thrown in The Dandy forgot
about the iron fleet and it was
disappointing etc the Battle of
Winterfell was dark but we do try to
bring something extra and show our work
and yeah finding things like we don't
have the men and the all of the bay like
you have to watch the show to do that no
we like to put in the trailers yeah
there's no way to fake that funk on a
nasty dunk or otherwise comment or a
mile day points out this is valid
where's Sansa in this trailer that's
here we go
whoops well every character yeah 25 edit
trailer but but what could not a cursory
looking like she's cool yeah so once is
cool because I've seen is pretty meet
her last shot it's cool I've always been
on Santa team Sansa yeah I like her
character too but like come on like she
really didn't have that much to do in
these last three she started there to
put pressure on Jon that's oh no that's
not our fault that's the game let's
remember where she started season six
but like she makes some shakes Ramsay
yeah and Fiamma strangely her arc was
too good to begin this trailers because
if in the middle of our trailer we're
like and Santa was really cool in high
police : amounts of smirk Andy Walsh
says you didn't talk about Danny's quick
change to madness at all fact-check yes
we did dc-8 1 9 8 8 says I was expecting
the Starbucks cup to make a cameo on
here guess I had to be disappointed one
last time backtrack we did it was a
billing service and crap so we love you
fans you you give it then you take it
away I guess also in the comments some
people were confused by the scene at 8
minutes 8 seconds not recognizing it was
during the nudie montage there was just
a giant closeup of a penis well that's
what it was if you're confused yeah but
it was and that's what it looks like it
was from when REO was with the actors
troupe the guy was like does this look
weird to you yeah it's got something on
there yeah we have that looked at a
professional and then Cesar Vargas wrote
his final comment that will discuss a
Breaking Bad still the greatest TV show
ever which prompts me to ask where does
Game of Thrones now rank on the all-time
best TV show they really they really
poop the bed stuff
daddy I agree and yet it still is in my
top five yeah I think probably closer to
five than one but yeah I think it went
probably about six to me just because I
judge best shows by rewatch ability and
like if there were if magically there
was one person in this world who had not
seen Game of Thrones
and was now interested in doing so I
don't know that I could give it a solid
recommend oh hey wow I disagree I think
when you take when we all take a step
back and watch the whole series I'm not
saying it's gonna make the ending better
but I think overall it will give the
series a boost in that it is still
exception
we're having that majority of its raw
having that break and having that
anticipation build I think it definitely
factors into a lot of the disappointment
yes I just started that go watch it
again like I walked out of the last you
know is that I think a lot of people had
that weird thing you know I know we have
a lot of friends in this field that are
like their wardrobe was ninety percent
Game of Thrones or people who might name
their kid Daenerys and stuff who are now
like guys huh like I pulled my Game of
Thrones socks that I pulled him out of
my drawer and was like wow the seasons
but I do not think it is this far
removed it's not throwing the socks out
man yeah put him away for later yeah I
mean I think there's really still only a
handful of drama series in history that
get anywhere near the level or the
ambition or the show which I the wire
Friday Night Lights or I don't I guess I
don't
there's too much TV I can't like I just
pretty much dead wood before the movie
and it's amazing and like I think
Deadwood I would rank above Game of
Thrones but there's not like Deadwood
Mad Men Sopranos Twin Peaks like I'm
already starting to run out of ideas
okay
Breaking Bad was a gift I get break bad
but rightly ten shows ever have done
with Breaking Bad in which is to to
maintain and I will also say season to a
Breaking Bad not graze not as good as it
is not as good as the rest of the show
it Breaking Bad also a season to curse
yeah I think that very few shows are
able to consistently deliver that level
of excellence for the majority of their
run Breaking Bad is one of a few of them
that that gets it mostly exceptionally
right but that is a hard standard
deliver yeah it's not bad
I love that show it's genius it is it's
a character study it's really gotta
deliver on do we feel satisfied by where
Walt's journey ends one way with
Jessie's journey adds it's not trying to
do what game of threats a lot different
to try to work that out yeah it's got a
lot
moving pieces they have balance so many
plates like the best show of all time
Guy Fieri's diners drive-ins and dives
[Laughter]
this is what we do every week over on
fan mantain but now it's on screen
junkies we hope you'll join us next week
same time same place but probably
shorter because we'll be doing a movie
next week oh I also forgot we will be
teasing next week's honest trailer right
here right now well I think of a tease
if you think of the magic word you'll
know what we're doing next week there it
is and we'll see you then thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]
you